first of all the challenges is that this
is a figure for who everybody has
something different and vested in you
know so there's always going to be
someone who's going to feel as if
something was not covered and that was
always a real that was always the the
the realization and you know for me this
was an origin story I mean this was
about a man and his company and how at
some point the company became the man
right and so how even when he was set
afloat and he was exiled for two almost
ten years how he was not quite home had
to come back having learned and so you
know and I wanted to keep it because
that we you know you know when you're
working in a weird way working with a
limited budget disallows a certain
amount but it also allows you to focus
there's so much to tell but I really
wanted to stay away from anything too
personal because that would be total
conjecture he was extremely private man
and even in the book that was written I
mean very little is known I mean that's
a first person sort of accounting of his
own life which is always a little
suspect but if you don't quite get it
and he was an enigma people who work
with we interviewed a lot of people and
people who work with him for 30 years
said I saw him every day and I don't
quite know if he knows if I had a kid or
if I was married I mean he didn't have
those kind of relationships um but I
mean you know for me what was
interesting was here's this man who we
remember as being that brilliant keynote
speaker in the mock black turtleneck in
the round glasses you know totally aware
of the cult mentality that was sort of
surrounding him in his product on some
level I mean I always sort of thought as
you know in sort of in investigating and
talking to people it became clear that
he understood for example that priests
were the black because they that he
would they the church wanted the
congregants to sort of only associate
them with God you know that they were
simply channeling and a vessel for God I
didn't want to see them as something
earthly and Steve at a certain point I
mean think of the discipline that every
time he went outside you wore black and
the girl at the same suit he understood
that he didn't want to be associated
with Steve he wanted to only be sort of
associated with the product right and
that's how he showed love because you
also struggled with human relationship
in sort of a Norton sort of a normal
socialized way yet you know the other
thing that struck me when I was
first coming on was that that same guy
who sort of has come to define the
keynote speech when he was younger
everybody said he was just very
frustrated had a very hard time
explaining things like the explainer had
a very difficult time explaining because
he was telling people things and he had
ideas that had not quite been invented
yet there wasn't quite a language for it
yet I always sort of thought it was akin
and I would talk to ash and about it's
like you have the cure for cancer and
you know it's going to save people's
lives but you don't have the
technological sort of verbiage for it so
you're here you you're trying to tell
people and you know there's that scene
with the MIT guy and he says I just
don't get it which is a simple human
things that he could get out and that
was Steve you know the people a lot of
the guys in the garage with the
exception of wa's because he's working
for the sony film but all those original
guys espinoza they said you know that
exact scene might not have happened but
that scene happened a hundred times you
know a lot of them a lot of the film so
you know for me I thought that there was
just a great sort of everyman entry into
the story you know I believe actors are
actors you know I remember my second
film I cast Kelsey Grammer as the
president and it was with Costner who
was a film presence right and so people
think well maybe he should do Chris
Cooper but I loved Kelsey Grammer you
know I didn't care you know we mean I
didn't have a prejudice for that as far
as so I entered this with that
predisposition meaning I didn't have a
sort of preciousness about it I thought
a few things one you know young steve
was a very passionate intense showman
especially in the time we were telling
which was his early 20s to his late 30s
and I thought Ashton was interesting I
thought that there was something curious
about it so I went to meet him and first
of all when you meet Ashton if you've
seen any of these interviews he has like
this encyclopedic knowledge of
Technology I mean he knows everything
and oh not only that but he deals with
people who are creating apps like uber
and Spotify and Airbnb these are all his
and so those kids that walk into his
office to try to have him invest and to
try to Shepherd them all have one idea
that they're obsessed with and that's
all they can talk about so he kind of
got the sense of what obsession was
which I thought was very important but
more than that
he cared he promised that he would do
the work which he did he went on the
fruitarian diet which was what Steve was
on and he was in not ended up in the
hospital because the he was this crap
quacky diet that Steve Jobs was on for
many years really thought great grapes
were we're extremely important in his
infan so just you know Ashton's insulin
level went up so he just immersed
himself in it and that in that first
meeting was like a master class and how
to take a meeting with the director
because he walked down the stairs and he
had and by the way this is all anyone
who knew Steve Jobs he had this loping
weird walk he had these sort of his hand
gestures were very specific he was very
intense and he walked in and he was not
quite doing it but he was doing it
enough that I kind of thought okay this
kids doing Steve Jobs for me and then
three hours into the meeting I kept
thinking she's he's doing Steve Jobs
this ashton and by the end of it I
realized he needed me to take away
evidence from this meeting like me I had
to go back and be able to say oh I could
see him and being Steve he knew I needed
to do that he's so smart I mean really
he's a smart I was very smart man so I
drove away and I was thinking two things
1i thought I got to catch a lot of
initial crap meaning the second i just
say to anybody you know because of the
drift that he brings to the party
secondly i thought but you know what
this is a very small film we have no
money to make it how are we going to
compete in a market that are all tent
pole studio films and how we making it
make this interesting how am I going to
think out of the box and there was
something curious there was a lot of
noise that I thought that ashton plain
dismayed and I thought if he could pull
it off if he could just be that role we
could work really hard and we did then I
think it would be successful I was a
long way of saying I went by the way he
looked just like him so yeah not that
didn't hurt you know and because you
know Steve Jobs is an ordinary guy he
was a guy in the valley and he was he
didn't have any of those idiosyncratic
things that a lot of really sort of
iconic people have so when you not
replace them you know it's the Ronald
Reagan thing or it's the it's you know
so Bill Clinton whatever you're gonna do
he was the guy he kind of had a way kind
of said I he spoke slowly he kind of had
a Midwestern father but he was also from
California Valley he kind of did a lot
you know he was justice so it was like
his it he
this increases we're very subtle so in a
weird way when you're an actor doing
small things are actually harder than
doing the big things like if he had some
crazy you know recognizable draw so we
worked very hard at trying to get those
and a lot of the guys who knew him I
mean we sweet we screened the film for
the original guys in the garage which
was you know the original garage like
Steve grew up in and they said thanks
for bringing him back any it not to
Steve that we all know but the Steve
that they knew you know for and so in a
long way of saying I think that's what
brought me to him all the guys who were
in this movie saw the movie were being
portrayed except for was who we had a
screening for them in the kid who the
guy who plays Chris Espinosa who was the
kid who didn't get to get to stocks he
saw he saw it twice and he he said gosh
he's not at Sundance he said gosh you
know he almost he he felt sort of
vindicated in that we had discussed the
fact that he didn't get it you know if
he sort of felt like he is now being
immortalized sort of given is due and he
said you know in a biopic you can't get
every detail right because it's like
when Sarah Palin saw a game change and
may have candies and that happened you
know but it basically happened all of it
happened but none of it happened exactly
of that way of course because we're
simply interpreting it